ce retraité de la bac de la brigade
anticriminalité de la police nationale
marc julien michon âgé de 68 ans reste
introuvable à ce jour malgré nos boss
battues organisées dans le secteur
aujourd'hui encore dès les premières
heures de la matinée
ses parents ses amis du quartier
dominante et bien d'autres volontaires
on se couchait sans succès durant
plusieurs heures différentes zones du
nord atlantique doivent être caché tout
cas tu es partie du sous fonds dominique
nora fait toujours bakkali les
couteliers ppi prix aura fait toute
grève doit affecter la faire le jour où
tu es là tu aimeras lieu d'une gêne au
goûter y at il des jaunes et là tu aimes
comme le groupe qui vont relever nous
quatre nous lever pour nos vielles à
roue et julien michalon surnommé zizi
résider ici et couler des jours
paisibles avec sa soeur dans cette
petite maison familiale sous les
hauteurs du quartier dominante au
marigot
il ya un tas à minuit
et à minuit et là j'en ai trouvé 1,6 ou
une chaise comme ça mais j'ai dit mais
qu'est ce fait la juger
il me dit c'est bon c'est bon je dis
mais non mais tu es toi ll lui entré ici
de l'est elle m'a dit de l'yvette dîner
au mien et moi aussi j'étais dans ma
chambre le lit matters ligne 10 pages
selon 7 par an le disparu présentait
depuis quelques mois des troubles du
comportement
il se déplaçait à l'aide de béquilles à
cause d'une récente fracture à la jambe
il devait se rendre en consultation sur
son médecin traitant
en début de semaine lors des derniers
d'un majeur devait accompagner mon frère
au laboratoire set mari parce qu'il
avait une une ordonnance du docteur nous
les eaux qui l'avait prescrit de faire
des analyses
puisque il souffre notamment de la
dépression
les battues ont été organisées par la
gendarmerie nationale un large périmètre
autour du domicile a fait l'objet de
recherches à l'aide de chiens de la
brigade cynophile des recherches qui
vont encore s'intensifier dans la
semaine